26 mai 2014
à 11h15 le matin voici ma tenue de
travail
je suis en mission scientifique sur le
volcan monado à hawaï à 2500 mètres
d'altitude et à une heure trente en
voiture de la ville la plus proche je
suis en mission scientifique et ce matin
là notre mission principale c'était de
vider nos toilettes sèches les bactéries
qui devait dégrader nos déchets ne se
sont pas correctement développer et donc
au moment de la photo nous nous
apprêtions à vis des deux mois de
déchets et de trois personnes
imaginez que cette mésaventure arrive
dans l'espace imaginez qu'elle arrive
sur mars
parce que c'est sur mars que nous étions
ou en tout cas nous 6 millions une
mission sur mars avec les contraintes
que cela implique des ressources
limitées en eau et énergie une
obligation de sortir en combinaison
spatiale sur mars
les contraintes seront tels que les
astronautes devront vivre en boucle
fermée avec leur environnement
sur terre on ne se pose pas ce genre de
questions
d'ailleurs jusqu'à aujourd'hui on a
toujours considéré la terre comme un
système ouvert dans lequel on peut
puiser des ressources à l'infini et
rejeter nos déchets à l'infini mais
cette époque est révolue
si nous voulons faire face aux
contraintes d'énergie et des espaces que
nous aurons demain il va nous falloir
faire autrement
faire autrement ça passe par plusieurs
choses ça passe par une meilleure
compréhension de nos écosystèmes et des
équilibres terrestre mieux faire le tri
entre ce qui est vraiment nécessaire à
notre survie et ce qui est superflu
ça veut dire aussi devenir plus
performant dans notre manière de
recycler les déchets et puis apprendre à
mieux vivre ensemble dans un monde aux
ressources limitées tant que les vastes
espaces que sont les océans les sols
l'atmosphère seront assez grand pour
servir de tampon les équilibres
terrestres seront robuste et résilient
mais au rythme où vont les choses nous
pourrons bientôt apparentés notre
planète
un espace confiné et dans un espace
confiné la moindre petite variation peut
avoir des effets dramatiques sur
l'équilibré d'un système entier par
exemple le problème que nous avons eues
avec nos toilettes sèches était due à
des températures trop basses
là une simple petite variation de
quelques degrés a failli engendré une
catastrophe sanitaire dans l'espace
confiné qu'était notre d'hommes la même
manière on a longtemps cru que les
plantes ne pouvait pas se développer
correctement en orbite terrestre à cause
des conditions d'apesanteur
or la pesanteur les plantes savent
relativement bien s'y adapter
le problème venait d'un manque de
ventilation l'air n'était pas assez
renouvelé et l'éthylène s'accumulaient
l'éthylène c'est une hormone produite
par les plantes
c'est elle qui est responsable du
mûrissement de vos fruits mais dans une
station spatiale qui est un endroit
confiné l'éthylène s'accumulaient
dépassent un seuil critique et inhiber
la croissance des plantes
alors de quoi avons nous réellement
besoin pour survivre
chaque jour il nous faut 800 grammes
d'oxygène 800 grammes d'oxygène ça
correspond à tout l'oxygène compris dans
3000 litres d'air au niveau de la mer
grosso modo le volume d'une cabine
d'essayage
il nous faut aussi 3,2 kg d'eau alors
cette eau on la retrouve dans ce que
l'on boit mais aussi dans ce que l'on
mange et il nous faut 600 g de matière
sèche ça on le retrouve dans ce que l'on
mange et s'est constitué principalement
de carbone pour une mission de 1000
jours avec un équipage de six personnes
vers mars par exemple ce minimum vital
représente tout de même 30 tonnes 30
tonnes c'est un gros camion
et quid des déchets parce que chaque
jour nous rejetons aussi 900 grammes de
dioxyde de carbone
nous rejetons 3,6 kg d'eau ça c'est de
l'eau qu'on retrouve dans notre ville
bien sûr mais aussi dans nos sel dans
notre transpiration dans notre
respiration et nous rejetons 100 g de
matière sèche que notre organisme n'a
pas consommé en ce qui concerne l'eau
d'hygiène on compte un minimum de 15
litres par jour et par personne
ces lots dont on a besoin pour faire sa
toilette lave linges laver la vaisselle
à titre de comparaison en france à
l'heure actuelle la consommation d'eau
moyenne par jour et par personne et de
100 litres
d'ailleurs une douche pour vous elle
dure combien de temps dix minutes
15 minutes parce que moi quand j'étais
sur mars
j'avais le droit à huit minutes d'eau
par semaine et j'ai réussi à en utiliser
que 4 alors quatre minutes d'eau par
semaine ça veut dire une bouche de une
minute à une minute trente
tous les deux ou trois jours et c'était
un luxe parce que les astronautes sur la
station spatiale internationale
ils n'ont pas de douche il utilise des
lingettes pendant toute la durée de leur
séjour qui dure entre cinq et six mois
et ils recyclent leurs urines aussi
alors bon ok ils n'ont pas de douche
mais ils peuvent se vanter de boire le
même café tous les jours pendant six
mois les quatre piliers fondamentaux de
la survie sont le renouvellement de
l'air le recyclage de l'eau la
production de nourriture et le
traitement des déchets un projet phare
de l' agence spatiale européenne sur
lequel j'ai la chance de travailler le
projet mélissa a pour but d'inclure ces
quatre piliers dans une boucle fermée
entièrement basée sur des procédés
biologiques
il s'agit de recréer l'écosystème d'un
lac de manière artificielle des microbes
dégrade les déchets organiques de
l'équipage alors par déchets organiques
là je parle pas seulement des épluchures
de pommes de terre et carottes 1 je
parle bien des excréments et de green
donc des microbes dégradent ces déchets
il en résulte une sorte de compost qui
sert à nourrir des plantes et des ald et
s'est planté ces algues comme vous le
savez absorbent le dioxyde de carbone
contenu dans l'air et produisent de
l'oxygène que l'on peut respirer
donc le gros avantage de renouveler
l'air avec des plantes c'est que ça
permet aussi de produire de la
nourriture est double avantage
les plantes permettent aussi de recycler
l'eau parce que quand elle transpire oui
les plantes transpire aussi donc
elle transpire et elle génère de la
vapeur d'eau de l'eau pure donc l'eau
est recyclée en ce moment même
d'ailleurs à barcelone il y à un
démonstrateur de cette boucle mélissa
des rats respire l'oxygène produit par
des algues et les algues utilisent le
dioxyde de carbone expiré par les rats
pour pousser et on a une jolie boucle
fermée
même en antarctique sur la station
européenne concordia alors l'antarctique
c'est un environnement qui est
extrêmement hostile les ravitaillements
sont très rares et bien le système de
traitement des eaux à concordia est
entièrement basé sur des technologies
mélissa alors recyclé prendre soin de
nos écosystèmes c'est bien mais ça ne
suffit pas saurons-nous vivre ensemble
lorsque nous serons 10 milliards sur
terre dans un monde avec des ressources
limitées les expériences en milieu
confiné comme celle à laquelle j'ai
participé montre que nous avons aussi à
progresser dans ce domaine pendant
quatre mois
j ai remarqué cap force d'être 24 heures
sur 24 ensemble des tensions
apparaissait mais on n'avait pas le
choix on ne fait pas s'exiler ou changer
de collaborateurs il fallait faire avec
jusqu'à la fin de la mission
alors on avait trouvé des stratégies
pour alléger l'atmosphère qui était basé
sur le jeu et l'humour et en particulier
on avait un jeu le jeu du rover qui
consistait à cacher un petit rover
aimanté comme suit vous avez derrière on
le cacher quelque part dans le dôme et
le lendemain la personne qui le trouvait
non seulement gagner des points mais
avait aussi le privilège
cachez le jour suivant alors moi j'ai
été la grande perdante à ce jeu je le
trouvais jamais et ça donnait lieu à de
nombreuses blagues de la part de mes
coéquipiers mais du coup c'était
vraiment un moyen de ressouder l'équipe
une fois aussi je me souviens je suis
rentré de sortie et ma chambre était
entièrement tapissé de post it
il y en avait partout sur les murs sur
le sol sur le bureau c'était incroyable
mettez vous à ma place
ça faisait trois mois trois mois et demi
que je n'avais pas eu d'événements
spontanés dans ma vie et la vie
coéquipières avaient décidé de nous
faire une grosse blague ça a été magique
ce soir là l'atmosphère était vraiment
légère et on a tous pris une chose
importante qui ressort également de ces
simulations de ses missions en espace
confiné
c'est que dans ces cas là on ne peut
plus faire passer son intérêt et son
confort personnel devant ceux de
l'équipe et de la mission si on fait ça
c'est l'échec garanti on ne pourra
jamais mener la mission à terme dans de
bonnes conditions et de la même manière
nous sommes tous ensemble ici sur ce
vaisseau spatial qu'est la terre et si
des pays continuent à considérer la
terre comme un espace ouvert avec des
ressources infinies
sans se soucier du reste de la planète
ce sera l'échec garanti pour nous tous
fin juillet 2014
j'ai émergé de quatre mois d'isolement
lorsque je suis entré dans le dôme
c'était la fin de l'hiver j'en suis
sorti en plein été une des choses qui
m'a peut-être le plus manqué cette année
là c'est de ne pas avoir eu de printemps
lorsque je suis sorti supris une grande
inspiration d'air frais le soleil car et
c'est ma peau c'est la première fois en
quatre mois plus tard dans la journée
j'ai senti l'odeur de l'herbe coupée
vous savez cette odeur caractéristique
lorsqu'on vient juste de tondre une
pelouse j'ai entendu le chant des
oiseaux et j'ai piqué une tête dans
l'océan est là ça m'a frappé j'étais en
train de redécouvrir toutes ces choses
que j'avais considérée comme acquise
tout au long de ma vie qui était pour
moi normal les saisons l'air frais la
chaleur du soleil les océans la faune et
la flore environnante
et si un jour toutes ces choses cessé
d'être
vous pensez que c'est de la science
fiction comme l'était aller sur la lune
au siècle dernier non c'est réel à plus
ou moins long terme
si on ne change pas nos habitudes de
consommation des ressources de la
planète toutes ces choses qui nous
entourent auront disparu alors je vous
pose cette question est ce que nos
maisons nos cités ne pourrait pas
s'inspirer des boucle fermée et de venir
à elle seule des machines à recycler
pour nous permettre à tous de vivre sur
terre durablement merci
[Applaudissements]